what I love about this movie is it is a
tension film
it's not a action film at all it's all
about the suspense it's all about the
tension it's all about the characters
it's about the humans and how these
amazing yet terrifying monsters are
affecting the lives of everyone around
them whatever route a typical writer
would take with this movie they kind of
did the opposite they went different
directions that the movie I felt could
it go mean I found a little
disappointing that whenever there was a
monster scene like oh here we go
it's like Godzilla first shows up and I
was [ __ ] cool when he when he first
starts walking on the land you see his
feet show up you're like oh [ __ ] it's
about to go down you see him roars it's
awesome snatched a black and I was like
okay I'm fine with that then the next
thing Godzilla it's like okay we're
smashing a black every time he shows up
yes
I appreciate it the first time but then
after a while is like I kind of want to
see some monster action happening and
right when they were like about to fight
like you took the first blow and then it
cut again yeah no we both look to each
other like are you getting there I want
to mention something about the
relationship is I'm I'm really glad that
they didn't do the cliche like she gets
mad at him cuz he's not home yet you
know or that she you know he didn't put
her first or her kid first I love that
they do that because in reality if your
husband's like in danger you're not
gonna get mad at him you know I mean
you're gonna just want him to be home
and I'm glad they did that because that
to me is more realistic yeah it's a
reboot but they they turn it into a semi
sequel cuz they honoring the original
Godzilla like they keep referencing back
to 1954 when that's like when the
original Godzilla came out I think it
was in 54 55 and it came out but they're
obviously referencing the original I
love the opening credits where it's like
it looks like eight millimeter film the
whole time like old documents that have
been yeah I doctored and facts have been
blacked out yeah yeah it looks like old
school footage of when they were really
trying to kill Godzilla and it was it
was [ __ ] it was like really cool to
see like this is actually a sequel in a
lot of ways guys into history too cuz
it's like those they did do nuclear
tests in the Pacific yeah it's
and it's it's repurposes it's like
retroactive continuity for history it's
like we weren't actually testing we were
trying to destroy if you were to take
out the that whole concept of what we
are anticipating and you just look at
this movie for what it is it's a damn
good film yeah it's a film yeah there's
a film itself it's not a popcorn
blockbuster they they actually took
Godzilla and made a film yeah you know I
feel like if they did you know show more
of him it would have kind of been like
another Transformers movie the first
time he uses the atomic blast or
whatever they [ __ ] call it the
grammar crap
that was really good see it in the tail
yeah like don't know if it's gonna be in
the movie yeah do it you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah it's really cool and like even the
action wasn't too fancy with the monster
fighting it was just right I'm like this
is how it looks like when monsters might
fight actually because they're huge
creatures isn't it it seems really
realistic though that seems weird to say
cuz monsters think that things are gonna
be realistic it's not hyper style and
like it looks really good and there were
a number of moments at least for me in
those Godzilla sequences where I audibly
was like whoa but it's not about like
crazy [ __ ] camera thing and bang you
know it's like just behold this for a
moment and take it in and that's where
all the wow factor comes from for me
anyway there was one scene that really
just kinda hit me it was really simple
but you kind of just see how destroyed
this city had gotten they jump off the
plane and they're just falling down the
way they fall down through the clouds
and it progresses from there being
Sunline at the top and going through the
clouds and then seeing you know just
this darkened area and then going
through the clouds again is pouring down
rain and you see just all this
destruction in a fire and that to me was
really really powerful it was a really
powerful shot
I like the San Francisco Bridge sequence
a lot too yeah like you know the more I
think about it the whole teasing
Godzilla throughout is actually better
than actually seeing him a lot because I
do like the perspective of they put you
in that kind of the view of not just one
character's perspective but a lot of
people if you take it from the children
on the bus just that even that action of
that bus driver being like
yeah I'm gonna jet was that was really I
was so happy but yeah I was like yeah I
probably do that too yeah well that's a
cool thing about this is there are a
number of those kinds of moments where
it's like this is how people are
behaving and we probably all would do
yeah they ask themselves a lot how would
someone react in this particular suit
rather than just run away and scream
they they actually took like logistic
steps based off who these people
probably are yeah so yeah so yeah
anyone got some reasons to see
essentially the writing I thought the
writing was incredible actually it was
surprisingly like one of the smartest
summer movies I've ever seen it was it
goes beyond a summer movie you could
release us any time of the year as one
of the smartest seasoned movies I've
ever seen I was really moved by it so
yeah it seems like it cares more than
just like come in here buy popcorn and
watch stuff explode you know I guess
piggybacking off that I'd say the the
direction is also definitely a reason to
see it makes a lot of really distinct
choices and is really well composed so I
thought the direction was great
and so I'd like to clarify I said in a
trailer that I thought this movie would
be the movie of the year and I stand by
that
I like the Aaron taylor-johnson a lot I
thought Aaron taylor-johnson was
actually quite awesome I bought him
instantly and I wasn't sure I was gonna
feel about it cuz the only thing I've
seen him is kick ass so the fact that
like I bought him instantly even at
first I was like oh he's a dad it was I
bought it and like I loved his
performance a lot very subtle but you
get everything behind him and he does
carry a lot of emotion and those
beautiful eyes I'd also have to say
Bryan Cranston for sure oh yeah yeah
hands down yeah he acts as a softness
nice there was no you know better way to
start the movie there was Bryan Cranston
even though he's only in for like 20 25
minutes maybe there is an evolution to
that little screen time he has you know
he starts off as just a regular dude who
regular engineer who just really loves
his family and everything in that but is
really into his job that that happy
birthday banner that he saw after
everything was destroyed really got me
even from the very first scene we see
him and he's into his job but for very
good reason yeah definitely on to
something and he played the crazed
conspiracy conspiracy kind of guy well
it's not over the top at all actually
it's
he didn't come across crazy to me but I
think believe yeah but it's really that
like a guy who just movies and he's not
insane and he wasn't to you know look to
hobo wish or anything so yeah but you
can to make sense why other people
thought he was insane yeah yeah but he
didn't play it open they probably very
differently yeah another reason I just
have to say Godzilla
generally everything to do with I
thought everything they did with the way
they handle him and just him himself or
itself was great I really liked guns ooh
I love God so after this like yeah and
see the effects are bomb facts and
cinematography was really good the music
is great Ken want to know so those are
the Felson you guys nobody ever did she
wasn't that great okay she's pretty she
kept being like I'm so sad but there are
no tears I was like I'm disagree I
bought her entirely tears though I kept
looking for them tears aren't aren't the
hallmark of emotion I mean I thought she
teared up night the Japanese kid on the
train liked him a lot
it's gonna be the star hey guys thanks
for checking out our review for godzilla
watch you go ahead scroll that comment
box below and what are those things a
you and nickname Godzilla and once
you've done with that once you click it
and click this button so you can see
more episodes of reasons to see ya and
Dan you guys can check out my playlist I
have a new video up about a petition a
certain petition and we should check it
out and last but not least if you like
getting updated annoyingly
since we post a lot of videos these days
you're gonna want to do this thing
subscribe write subscribe do that isn't
Godzilla a woman might be
I thought Godzilla's a female I think we
discovered it oh well in the roland
emmerich version at least I thought like
any actual original Godzilla Godzilla
female what are Godzilla meets with
maybe Jackie chin that's China second
order so what if it's China I think I
should know King you think Peter
Jackson's King Kong and throw them in
there God be cool it'd be really cool
really that would be happy if they
didn't updated Godzilla versus King Kong
movie am i there that would be like that
would be worth my time
and then they got Gareth Edwards to
direct all the Godzilla scenes and Peter
Jackson to direct all the King Kong
scene yeah and then Jackie Chan has
their stunts exact